And, of course, there are much more sophisticated pre-processing rules
than the one that we have discussed here,
which, unfortunately, lie outside the scope of this course.
But there's one final question about pre-processing
that I would like to discuss with you, and that is when to apply pre-processing.
And this is one you'll have to think through a bit.
Is it before starting the search tree--of course,
you start the algorithm and not the tree, but you know what I mean.
Is it at each level of the search tree?
Is it regularly during the search tree algorithm?
Or is it after the search tree is completed?
So, again, you might have to think these through a little bit
and then please check each one that is correct.